>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
CONTINUING TO GIVE NEWS
CONFERENCES TO GIVE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS UPDATED ON THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC BUT THERE ARE
SOME IN THE MEDIA WHO ARE
CALLING FOR NETWORKS TO STOP
AIRING THEM LIVE.
WATCH.
>> I’M NOT SURE THAT WE SHOULD
CARRY THAT LIVE.
I THINK WE SHOULD RUN SNIPPETS.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO IT
AFTERWARDS AND GET THE PERTINENT
POINTS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BECAUSE HE IS NEVER, EVER GOING
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
>> IT’S ABOVE MY PAY GRADE, IT
SEEMS CRAZY TO ME THAT EVERYONE
IS STILL TAKING THEM.
>> IF IT WERE UP TO ME, AND IT’S
NOT, I WOULD STOP PUTTING THOSE
BRIEFINGS ON LIVE TV.
NOT OUT OF SPITE BUT BECAUSE IT
IS MISINFORMATION.
>> Dana: MY NEXT GUEST SAYS IT
IS GOOD THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DOING THIS PRESS CONFERENCES, SO
HE SAYS MAYBE THEY SHOULD NOT BE
LONGER THAN 30 MINUTES.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER
WHITE HOUSE SECRETARY
ARI FLEISCHER JOINS ME NOW.
I THINK IT’S KIND OF STRANGE
THAT SOMEBODY WOULD NOT WANT TO
COVER THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE ONE
OF THE THINGS I FIND IS THAT IN
THESE PRESS BRIEFINGS, SOMETIMES
THE PRESIDENT BURIES THE LEDE.
SO HE HAS THESE LITTLE NEWS
NUGGETS THAT HE SPRINKLED
THROUGHOUT, SO I FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE TO BE PAYING ATTENTION THE
ENTIRE TIME.
>> THIS IS REALLY DISTRESSING,
THE IDEA THAT IN A CRISIS LIKE
THIS, THEY WERE A PEOPLE WHO
DON’T WANT THE PRESIDENT TO BE
SEEN ON TV AND IT’S NOT BECAUSE
HE IS ACCURATE OR INACCURATE,
IT’S ACTUALLY BECAUSE HIS
RATINGS, JOB APPROVAL IS GOING
UP.
THAT’S THE REASON.
HIS JOB APPROVAL WAS GOING DOWN,
THEY’D BE THE FIRST TO INSIST ON
BROADCASTING IT LIVE.
THAT’S WHAT’S DRIVING THEM.
AND THEY CAN’T STAND TO SEE THE
PRESIDENT HAVE ANY KIND OF
SUCCESS.
IT’S BAD FOR DEMOCRACY WHEN
PEOPLE START CALLING ON THE
MEDIA TO CENSOR THE PRESIDENT AT
A TIME LIKE THIS.
IT’S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
DOING.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
AND WE ARE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
CHINA AND YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WHO IS OUT
THERE EVERY DAY TAKING QUESTIONS
FROM A LOT OF REPORTERS FOR AS
MANY MINUTES AS THEY WANT TO GO
ON LAST NIGHT AND SPEAKING OF
THE INTERNATIONAL ANGLE,
SECRETARY POMPEO WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS CRITICAL NEED TO GET
TRANSPARENCY UNDERWAY AND GET
ACCURATE NUMBERS FROM PLACES
LIKE CHINA.
LISTEN.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR DOCTORS TALK
ABOUT RISK HIM AND TALK ABOUT
FATALITIES TRYING TO THINK ABOUT
HOW TO MODEL WHAT THEY NEED IS
DATA.
THEY NEED DATA FROM ITALY, THEY
NEED DATA FROM CHINA, THEY NEED
DATA FROM IRAN.
THEY NEED EVERY COUNTRY TO STEP
UP AND PROVIDE ACCURATE
TRANSPARENT INFORMATION.
WE CAN’T HAVE THAT, IF WE HAVE
DISINFORMATION INSTEAD, THERE
WERE MORE LIVES THAT WILL BEGIN
RISK NOT ONLY TODAY BUT IN THE
WEEKS AHEAD AS WE BATTLE THIS
ENORMOUS CHALLENGE.
>> Dana: I THOUGHT THAT WAS SO
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE ARE
ASKING THEIR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON THE DATA THAT THEY HAVE
AND WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DATA IS ACCURATE NOT JUST FOR
THE UNITED STATES COME UP THE
GOOD OF THE WORLD AND WE HAVE
TWO IN SOME WAY MAKE CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
>> NO QUESTION.
AND I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
PRESS IS TOUGHER ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAN THEY ARE ON
PRESIDENT XI BUT THEY SEEM TO BE
GIVING THEM A GENERAL PASS FOR
THIS.
IN FACT, THEY’VE NOW SURPASSED
CHINA.
HE BELIEVES THAT?
THE PRESS REPORTS SAID ANYWAY
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY WOULD
HAVE TO CHALLENGE CHINA.
AND THEY JUST DON’T SEEM
INTERESTED IN THAT.
THERE’S NO UPSIDE TO THAT FOR
ACCURATE OR HONEST REPORTING.
SO AGAIN, MANY REPORTERS ARE
DOING THEIR BEST TO AS
SCIENTIFIC QUESTIONS BUT THEY’RE
STILL TOO MUCH OF A STRAIN IN
THE MEDIA WHERE IT WAS JUST
POLITICALLY CONFRONTING
EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING
DONALD TRUMP DOES AND REALLY
GIVE CHINA A PASS.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO CUT IT FOR
THIS CRISIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT DEEPER,
FULLY REPORTING.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING IS,
JOURNALISTS HERE IN AMERICA
REALLY COULD HELP THEIR FELLOW
JOURNALISTS IN CHINA IF THEY
WERE TO SHINE A LIGHT ON WHAT’S
HAPPENING THERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THAT NOTION OF TRANSPARENCY
WHICH THE PRESS SHOULD BE FOR,
WHAT YOU’D LIKE TO SEE IN THE
ROSE GARDEN AND THE BRIEFING
ROOM, THE PRESIDENT DOING HIS
PART I WOULD ARGUE, IT SHOULD BE
APPLIED TO CHINA AS WELL.
SHOULD BE APPLIED TO THESE
ADVERSARY NATIONS, WE CAN’T GIVE
THEM A PASS IN THE MEDIA SHOULD
NOT BE THE ONES YIELDING,
ACQUIESCING, NOT HOLDING THEIR
FEET TO THE FIRE FOR POINTING
OUT THAT CHINA’S NUMBERS ARE NOT
RELIABLE.
THAT SHOULD BE A REGULAR PART OF
ALL THEY REPORTING ON THE
NUMBERS FROM CHINA.
WE PUT THOSE AFTER THINGS WERE
SPORTS, WHY ISN’T THERE
THEREFORE THESE CHINESE
STATISTICS?
>> Dana: I LIKE THAT.
I’M GOING TO MAKE A GRAPHIC WITH